bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
pour la suite de ce championnat du monde
2016 entre temps que magnus car c'est le
tenant du titre i sergueï kaliakine donc
les deux joueurs sont à égalité on va
voir tout ça tout de suite avec le petit
petit résumé ici voilà que je vous
propose
très simplement ici donc on voit donc
après cette partie donc là on est sur la
huitième donc elles comptent pas de
genre sur l'égalité à 3 et demi 3 me sur
bilan rapide voilà donc on est à la
maintenant huitième partie donc arsène à
les blancs on approche de la fin du
match un petit peu dans la deuxième
moitié ça y est ça commence à ce concert
devenir de plus en plus tendus les douze
parties approche ou en huitièmes errance
encore pas mal car c'est un aller blanc
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il est ce qu'il
va continuer à jouer à jouer contre l'as
la défense de berlin de de karuïa qui
nous qualifie in va-t-il variés on va
voir ça tout de suite avec le premier
coup de quatre scènes et non pouf
voilà des quatre il revient car s'il
revient c'est son style à carsen de
tenter sur comme ça de surprendre
l'adversaire sous pleine ouverture
différentes il revient donc sur le sur
le premier coup du peu du match
puisqu'il avait démarré voilà par le
coût du kwh en dames et c'est parti pour
carrier qui n'est qu'à lévis quels
effets 3d 5
tout ça est connue 3e 6 en début pour
l'instant de type peut-être camby dames
après fou détroit csn pour les blancs
n'ont pas encore joué c4 et les noirs
eux mêmes jouent c'est celle bon ben
c'est connu un essai petit l'ouverture
on pousse le pion c'est ici souvent
avant de jouer le cavalier sinon on a
pas de rupture il faut avoir des
ruptures c'est important pour pouvoir
ensuite libéré les tours plus tard donc
provoquer les échanges dans le cas des
changes en plus ici belle et blonde
perdant échangé pendant que le noir
reprend reprend
on du fou pour gagner un temps donc
souvent les bleus ne prennent pas et
voilà donc il joue b3 ici voilà ici une
sorte de développement du fou là sur
l'ale ici soit en b2 sont à 3-3 pas
l'idée des blancs et aussi on pourra
jouer c4 est comme ça en cas de prison
pour ramener un pion vers le centre dans
tout ça est classique il n'y a pas grand
chose pour l'instant à dire fawcett
petit rock petit rock développement
propre des deux côtés standard dans ce
type d'ouverture et la fougue et de
trouver 2 du bon qu'on a joué 3 et qu'on
envisage pas avec les noirs de prenant
des quatre pour l'instant et bien on
joue en d2 à tout moment les blancs
peuvent prononcer 5 et on vise ces
cantonales en cas de prisons des quatre
on pourrait reprendre du fou pour garder
la colonne la diagonale ouverte ou bien
du pion et dans ce cas là le fou
soutient le pion pour aller mettre un
cavalier ou 5
et puis ensuite on joue f4 pour sûr
protégé le caillou 5 par exemple là tout
cas il est bien placé sous ici c'est
certain pessimisme noir veulent faire
pareil puisque il a le même
problématique le fou c'est 8 est lui
aussi bloqué par le pion u6 et donc le
sortir en bessette pour protéger bien
sûr via des 5 à 15,4 par transparence
ici on vise la protection de cette case
centrale importante où on peut mettre un
cavalier plus tard ou alors on peut
aussi jouer le fou en a6 à le fou ici
peut venir en a six parce que là il vise
cette diagonale et s'échanger contre le
fou de cases blanches entre possibilité
qui au procès cinq boules et blanc est
fou prend alors les noirs jouent un coup
contre intuitif je veux dire ici un
petit peu ils reprennent du fou alors
qu'il est conseillé par fille dort
depuis longtemps déjà qu'en cas de
prisons reprend du pillon bon on reprend
dukurs les noirs veulent pas jouer sans
doute ici en cas de prise du pion ils
ont effectivement une belle chaîne de
pions mais les blancs rouges ou et c4 et
en cas de prisons dessins qu'il faut
reprendre du pillon pour pas à garder un
pion est tout seul un pur isolé si on
reprend dès 5 ans suit avec une pièce
donc avec ses 4 si on prend le pion c5
sera isolé et si on laisse prendre les
blancs il faut reprendre du pied aux
escales on a ce qu'on appelle des pions
pendant qu'on aurait des pions c5 et des
qui on allait avoir des avantages les
inconvénients c'est très dynamique
puisque l'homme peut avancer ou l'autre
mais une fois que l'un avancé aussi bien
ils se retrouvent bloqués sur les cases
de couleurs opposées et donc qu'ils
peuvent devenir une cible
voilà avantages et inconvénients des
pions des pions pendant qu'ils ont
pendant l'appel ça comme ça et puis
c'est pas des purs isolé mais ils sont
que deux coin de vincent le petit duo
quoi voilà il veut pas jouer avec ça
notre ami kayak in donc il prend avec
fou prend ccnq nous pas de pions pendant
à l'horizon donc cavalier d2 tranquille
car c'est une finition développement
foulée cette karekin dès le 2 voilà on a
lié les tours voilà c'est toujours
intéressant trouver une bonne case pour
la dame préfère la mettre en deux que
plus tard après ces quatre là mètres en
c-2 pourquoi pas bon en deux mais aussi
d'un problème dans le deux bien sûr on
est derrière le pion on peut envisager
de plus de 4% entre voilà on est bien
placé on a lié les tours quelle et b17
les noirs c'est pareil alors on se poser
la question si vous mettre la dame en
ces sept on pourra avoir un vis-à-vis
avec une tour parce que tôt ou tard les
blancs rouges ou c4 crise on dessine
peut-être ils à tours la dame sera en
vis-à-vis dollars en recettes pour aussi
être envisagée d'am-dam c'est pas mal
donc ces quatre voilà c'est l'heure pour
les blancs sur c'était à eux de voile à
ses cadres alors soit les noirs prennent
ce cas là et blanc sans doute reprenons
du cavalier avec une très belle un très
beau contrôle de la case de 5 à l'aide
du fou voilà on comprend cette idée de
fou c'est le cavalier bien on a deux
carrés l'équipe eu l'air on s'est
protégé par le fu bo contre le central
c'est bien voilà l'idée standard
comprend ces quatre voilà c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui se passe que les princes et
4 et donc voilà 15,5 belles belles cases
1 pour les pièces blanches
éventuellement bon apprécié non plus on
va mettre des tours vers le centre on
peut mettre une tour anciens une tour en
d1 sans doute c'est les meilleures
classes pour le taux on peut c'est aussi
d'envisager de doubler les tours sur une
colonne je ne sais pas faut voir
dams est hélas alors un petit coup de
carsen tranquille semble pas absolument
nécessaire mais bon
à 3 bronze mauvais à 3 j'empêche aussi
ce cavalier bouche bée est forcément les
noirs pour y jouer fou à 3 échanger se
fouler voir les blancs veulent peut-être
pas donc il le joue à trois avec l'idée
b4 et une foot obligé de partir je peux
peut-être échangé le fou pour gagner et
perdre de fou donc les noirs ne laisse
pas faire il joue à cinq normales pour
empêcher empêcher des 4 et y laisser
leur fou sur ces scènes sur tout et ne
pas échanger ce fou contre le cab les c4
en recul indécise car les prend et
normal pas à donner la paire de fouet
mais sur ici les d4 bons coups centrale
bon vous pouvez aussi envisager
peut-être de mettre en scène bon mais
c'est beaucoup voilà on met le carillon
de d4 maintenant que les noirs ont joué
à saint louis lacasse b5 un peu faible
voilà car cindy mais voilà j'étais forcé
à jouer à ça maintenant je peux mettre
en cave à lyon de 5 est bon en tout cas
des quatre suis bien aussi voilà si tu
joues ascent bas je peux jouer carlier
f5 et c'est toujours un très très bon
cavaillon et sénas qu'est la dame est
attaquée pas facile de savoir où la m
voilà donc le noir ne craque pas
tranquillement tour yves des huit pas de
problème tous rêvent d un et noirs des
blancs aussi la centralisation des tours
voyez comme ses propres un vraiment une
partie modèle interne développement des
deux côtés la ses propres tour à ses
huit tours à ses standards cavaliers
fuite
et là un coup un peu curieux de carson
mais bon qui va pas être mauvais bien
entendu demeure dans le vin peut-être
ici il ya deux idées je libère la case
aux deux alors ce qui permet aux fous de
venir en f1 c'est le premier point et 28
jeunes cavaliers des cats pourrait venir
à eux deux aussi puisque j'ai libéré
aussi cette case pour revenir ensuite en
c3 parce qu'il irait faire là mais ça
pourrait être ça mais surtout peut-être
de preneurs et aussi j'ai un oeil sur la
carte b4
je pourrais aussi venir cavaliers en c2
qui permettrait de jouer b4 voilà ce que
maintenant je protègerai la classe b 4
avec le pion la dame
le cavalier et se [ __ ] obligé de
revenir en arrière
voilà donc deux idées avec ce coût moyen
des coussins plein d'idées
ça suffit calé j'ai six pour les noirs
bon pas de problème car aucune estime
qu'il n'y a pas grand chose à faire
il remet son câble est en position
active ici en justice alors qu'il était
en fuite fouet fin voilà le blanc
maintenant ramènent leurs fous en effet
le fou a toujours une idée ici de
contrôle sur la classe b sun qin case un
outil où on peut mettre un cavalier ça
peut être intéressant puisque dès le cas
dès que le cavalier c4 bougeait bien la
case b5 et protégé par le fou et en même
temps en jouant fouet fin et bien cette
tour dès maintenant à une meilleure vue
un an le camp adverse allait moins gênés
par le fou calais g4 alors ça c'est un
coup rétention de tendue faut faire très
attention avec les blancs que les g4
coup actifs
maintenant il ya plus de l'adamant le 2
mai sur ce cas il peut venir là ils
peuvent eux maintenant les noirs
regarder m cavalier hossein qui c'est
envisageable il faut que ton faire des
calculs cavaler prendre cali prend à
temps sur lequel est un peu en l'air
quand même puisqu'il ya le fu chi pour
l'attaqué on pourrait sacrifier ce
cavalier peut-être pas où on c6 ou je ne
sais où pour prendre celle qui sait
peut-être pas intéressant mais ça c'est
une possibilité mais aussi surtout on
attaque h 2 ici ce qui fait comme coup
comme dame c'est cette pouf menace maths
ou un coup comme dame h4 menace
maintenant c'est une menace face il
apparaît est juste il faut quand même
faire attention le cou à un couac des
sites comme ça c'est les types de
menaces qu'il faut calculer parce que si
à la fin d'une variante on n'a pas vu ce
coup qui peut derrière attaqué une pièce
par exemple c'est pas bon donc faut
faire attention
cavell et bessèges voilà talibés 5 le
cavalier protégé à un petit point de
transparence par le fou il suffit de
bouger ce cas valises et ses 4 on
envisage d'échanger des tours pourquoi
pas et puis on vise la casse des six
voilà envisager de pénétrer sur la case
des six pas tout de suite c'est bien
protégé par les noirs mais faut faire
des calculs
au regard des caisses d'ici c'est un peu
un peu attaqué sur mario à mettre en
quarantaine et si c'est pénible parce
que là on attaquera la tour c 8 le full
ace est bon c'est pas possible tout de
suite mais il suffirait de protéger une
fois de plus la case de cazaux des six
pour que ce soit possible par exemple ou
4,5 et pouf une case une pièce en d6
voyez ça peut aller vite alors on peut
pas tout de suite a joué 4
non plus ce qui est le fou c'est celle
qui attaquaient f2 voilà h4 aussi bon
voila mais il est là le cavaly bsn faut
y faire attention énorme attaque en
disant bon mais ok certes le fou pearn
transparence mais maintenu en tant que
cavalier label moi je le prends
c'est sûr donc faut que les blancs
réagissent donc à 4 voilà bon mais c'est
bien beau mais là où les noirs on vous
assène que les blancs jouent à 4 donc
les noirs ont réussi à équilibrer le jeu
voilà tu as une petite faiblesse en d4
aussi je peux mettre mon fou attaqué la
dame bon donc bien joué deux quarts
yakine tranquille pas deux pas de grand
problème des choses à vérifier mais n'y
a pas de menace
à noter aussi que les structures de
pions sont parfaitement symétrique à
quatre baies 3 à 5 des 6 et l'a donc 3
et 2 g de h2 contre eux aussi sept g7 à
cette asymétrie est un facteur
d'équilibré ou des scènes voilà un fou
bien placé au centre qui en transparence
attaque le pion b3 ce qui rend ce
cavalier c4 un peu immobile l'a pas
facile de savoir comment le bouger sans
bien sûr avant un problème sur b3 donc
un fou aussi bien plat bien placés en
dessin puisqu'il est protégé par un pion
voilà c'est souvent un très bon une très
bonne case au centre pour un fou quand
il est protégé puisqu'il est à la fois
il rayonnait de deux côtés ce fou à la
fois il a un oeil sur les dames et
notamment le câble et ses cadres mais
surtout le plan b 3 ce qui mobilise un
peu justement ce cavalier et en même
temps et sur les droits en bon père
quitte toute légère pression sur
l'europe mais très léger et puisqu'on
est très très bien protégés côté rock
mais on sait jamais
food et 4 les blancs décident d'échanger
ce fou se fout c'est 5 alors l'idée sans
doute c'est que après les changes
dessous
mais l'idée de 4 j'attaque le fourbe et
t5 qui par 1,5
je contrôle la casse des six la dame
protège les ici en simple cavale et
protège et la case des six peut être une
case d'invasion voilà les blancs
envahissent le camp noir via un pion le
signe qu'ils contrôlent des 6es pour ça
mais je doit éliminer ce fou parce que
je peux pas jouer le 4 et cause de ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure le fou ces
cinq attention à case attaque f2 avec
lecavalier
elle se calme menaçant donc
fou prend ses 4 pour les blancs pas mal
il dit bon ok mais en fait je peux aussi
prendre ce qu'alice qui fait que ça sera
très difficile d'envahir la casse des
six sites en a qu'un seul ça sera plus
dur en tout cas donc il élimine donne la
paire de fou quand même ici car yakine
bon pourquoi pas un peu tendu ton est
donné par de full tilt est membre un
champion et tout calculer on va voir
tout reprend et choisit de prendre avec
la tour carsen peut-être qu'il veut
doubler
voilà on sorte à une tour eh bien il
peut être le premier à doubler des tours
ça peut être pas mal fo prend maintenant
le d4 donc là les noirs donne la peur de
fou contre la havane où il n'a pas la
paire de faux maintenant puisqu'il vient
charger en échange vous donc ya pas de
perdre fout pas de problème donc ici
pour prendre des quatre pour des
prendrait quatre bons tranquille où il
aurait pu doubler aussi bon je suis pas
pour ces prenait 4,6 bien aussi bon mais
en fait il aurait changé une tour en
commun graves puisque là il va en
échange de tourner dans tous les cas
c'est ce qu'il fait d'ailleurs un cas
qui nie les charges et là où un peu
surprenant quand même deux car c'est là
à suivre peut prendre de la tour bon à
la position reste symétrique mais il
choisit de prendre du plomb sens assez
tendu parce qu'évidemment en faisant ça
belisol deux pions à quatre essais 4
surtout à 4 puisque c4 est protégé bon
ça va dans la tour mais sûr mais surtout
par le fou pas facile d'aller attaquer
ce pion mais surtout le pion à quatre
c'est pas simple il va suffire de jouer
damas trois d'un bep quatre mêmes
membres échangent des hommes et dames à
trois et c'est pas celle là les protège
espion donc c'est un peu tendu quand
même là ce que je choisis car scène mais
bon ils jouent pour l'activité bon à
noter aussi que attention pour les noirs
le cloud étant prises ici faut réagir
lorsqu'ils font tout de suite il
pourrait alors ciprel s'il avait pris
ici
les noirs cité sans doute un peu tendu
après tout reprendre en d4 les blancs
auraient repris depuis peu voilà avec un
dieu de pions menaçant on menace tout de
suite pourquoi pas 2006 puisqu'on peut
pas à si on peut réussir que
d'entreprendre
bon c'est jouable aux étudiants par
exemple ce n'est pas un cas un coup
comme à l'étudiant le coup comme à les
cavaliers damas les dames des huit
daumas les dames à trois dames à 3 et
une dame à trois dames à 3 ça va pas
maintenant quelques tuyaux il ya le
travail et donc on va jouer un coup
comme une prophétie trouver un coup
d'ailleurs parce que dans le but d'en
venir on the damned et vitaly d'amd 8
par exemple pour venir en b 8 pour
menacer h de la place et mat on habite
hélas les blancs pour jouer simplement
wallace c5 puis on prend puis on prend
un avion passe et on veut par la mena
sont contre par g3 et on va mettre le
feu au sud tous les deux on a pu
repasser
si on reste ici on joue pas facile trou
d'un coup ça le problème
imaginons qu'on joue h6 par exemple
wall5 c'est jouable aussi h5 et bien
dans ce cas là les blancs pourrait quand
même joué ces cinq apparemment c'est
simple puisque après pions prince et 5
les blancs on pourrait soit prendre ses
seins mais surtout peut-être joué
d'abord h trois cavaliers à 6 et
maintenant voilà on peut prendre c'est
celle où prendre directement à 5
voilà c'est que la dame ici attaque le
pion à 5 voilà c'est un peu un peu aussi
l'idée on peut prendre d'abord ensuite
prendre à cette nouvelle mesure passée
voyez donc voilà c'est un peu tendu donc
ici puis on prend tout reprend puis on
prend donc les noirs en prenant ici
permettent la poussée ces cinq donc avec
cette fameuse ici voilà on voit
l'intérêt de la dame en vain aussi
secoue un peu mystérieux l'un d'eux car
scène commence à avoir du sens donc les
droits rebelles reculent voilà ils
auraient pu le h5 pour laisser le câlin
jeu 4 on aurait pu chasser par h3 donc
il recule tout de suite bon pourquoi pas
la dame des deux car samedi
écoute voilà qu'est ce tu fais si tu
prends je prends du pillon c5 à venir
avec soi un pion patience et 5 selon que
la dame joue pas soit on va prendre à 50
pions de passer en a quatre et je vous
tendu là car ce n est pas mal ça comme
des deux donc là les noirs jouent au
calme tourbes et 8
voilà pas mal non cas de ses cinq
missions prendront pas de voile a pas de
problème puisque tu m'attaques et la
tour j'ai pas envie de prendre
j'ai bien compris que tu voulais prendre
du plomb et tu te crées un pur passé
avec un fou qui pièce longue pièce le
mieux c'est-à-dire défensive en g2 mais
en même temps support d'un pion passé
qu'ils pourraient avancer
ah oui c'est vrai ça peut être embêtant
lang à papillons pas c'est tomber 8
taquine solide
j 3 donc c'est bien une petite pression
malgré ses pions isoler les finalement
bon voilà à l'idée de l'art scène
commence à comprendre g3 on va pouvoir
jouer plus tard fou j'ai deux en cas de
poussée de prise et de machins le fou
j'ai deux par exemple ici en cas de
c'est simple on prend dans prend que
j'étais contre la case de promotion du
pion voyez un temps songé trois bombes
et je donne une petite fenêtre au roi
aussi donc tranquille telle cette
attention
évidemment grosse fourche est la triple
trois bons championnats du monde quand
même
voilà où j'ai deux on le voit car ce
n'est pas un problème
6 un petite fenêtre pour le roi
attention puisque le roi a lui aussi
commencé à éditer en couloir et on va
c'était l'heure de commencer à donner un
peu d'air et maintenant personnes ont
joui pts 1/4 scène la f4 en avant boum
le cloud est attaqué attention parce que
le pur 3 est un petit peu faible le roi
doit alors à blanc devient un petit peu
aussi en aérien là c'est à dire qu'il
est un petit peu en l'air non pourra
plus tard jouer à trois rouages de le
mettre à l'abri
donc il veut gagner de l'espace il joue
joutes rendu car centrowitz vraiment
agressif là malgré ses le fait qu'il est
isolé ses pions on l'a toujours
attention attention maintenant ce qui
est un peu embêtant aussi avec elle
quatre c'est que le jour où les noirs
envisagerons de jouer damas trois
cavalières à bouger attaque à quatre
attaques ou 6 3 on pourrait sans cavani
tient sûrement pas un peut pas venir
donc cavalier e 17
voilà une sur le cavalier attention
maintenant pareil pions isoler la le cas
vaillance et 5 sera magnifique bloc
l'option c4 attaque à quatre sa salle
est embêtant quand même les noirs ont
quand même ici la position - gallen en
étant précis malgré l'espace là que
prend carcelle a caressé 5 semble
largement suffisant pour avant une
position quand même extrêmement solide
pour pas dire inrocks il s'est même les
blancs qui à mon avis sont un peu
embêtés avec le pion à 4 mais sans plus
ce qu'ils ont quand même la colonne des
ils ont de l'espace devant protéger à
quatre ça peut se faire facilement par
d'âme des uns et les noirs n'ont pas
grand chose il ya quand même le fou
aussi se fout là de pièces longues
compteront cavaliers kalia cette voie là
attention car celle là rentrer dans
quelque chose ici avec calais à 7
il choisit de jouer un coup tendu qui
menace une fourchette ça c'est un
premier point mais qu'on l'a vu tout à
l'heure
lada maintenant peut venir à 3 donc ça
attaque 1,4 et en même temps on peut pas
faire ce qu'on veut trop avec les blancs
puisque et le pion aux 3 est attaqué
donc c'est ce que fait heins
c'est ce que va faire carrière qui nous
regardent et un très joli coup pouf
damas trois positions toujours tendue
mais sans plus
bon les blanches attention il ya une
pièce en l'air puisque tout reprend clé
prendre un point de gagné une pièce mais
à la fois le cul en quatre et en prix
mais surtout le tueur 300 imaginons que
les blancs prennent maintenant tout de
suite en 17
c'est ça qu'a joué que quelques clara
keynes et un cou tendu un ski la fedama
trois là là il faut reprendre dans prend
et j'ai deux pièces mineurs contre une
tour c'est avantageux interne matos mais
c'est un honneur de jouer aura pris dame
prend 1,3 qu'est ce qu'on fait si on
vient h1 dames c'est un échec
faux f1 dimpre en maths
et oui aux achats mat après adam c1 on
peut pas on est dans un quasi couloirs
et sur dame et suroît pardon f-16
simplement les noirs pourraient
simplement harceler le roi soit par
damas chèque ou même par des coûts plus
simples comme dame b3 et je menace de
prendre ces quatre avec échec et la tour
pourra peut-être plus tard aussi venir
aider mais en tout cas le roi blanc on
voit bien qu'il est il est en l'air
voilà on peut continuer aussi à faire
des échecs par dame c est sans doute
prendre ces quatre ou ce genre de choses
donc bon il est en l'air et ça suffit
pour soi avoir un échec perpétuelle soit
10 rebonds mais ok mais une pièce de
plus mais on fait avec ce type d'échangé
là elles auront en l'air tu vas tu vas
pour éviter l'échec perpétuelle tu vas
devoir donner tous les pions et à la fin
j'en ai suffisamment de pions pour pour
compenser ce ce léger des avantages
matériels
j'ai beaucoup d'activités voilà pour
contre le matériel c'est ça l'idée un
donc ici sur damas trois avenants carsen
ne craque pas et jouent le plus le fort
qui avait laissé 6 voilà il ramène son
cavalier c'est ce qu'ils voulaient faire
un jour travaillé un set il attaque la
tour
foccart al-hakim fasse quelque chose
donc ils gardent le contrôle ici du pion
3 il n'est ce pas bien sûr qu allah qui
ne rentrait dans le même perpétuer il
joue pour le gala carsen il met la
pression à tranquille tu aurais fuite
voilà touré fuite sans doute sa
meilleure case bon on peut ne pouvait
pas venir ensuite attaqué le cavalier
puisqu'il y avait cavaliers enfin on
pouvait pouvez quand même si vous
regardez tour c'est 8 peut pas jouer qui
a eu lieu cet échec puisque la dame ici
bien sûr les temps étant à 3 mais là
sans doute oui c'est toujours comme ça
le problème c'est qu'on est obligé de
laisser à damas trois sinon il ya la
fourchette bombes et les blancs et puis
dans ce cas là bas jouer h 3o mettront à
l'abri continuer leur leurs affaires bon
c'était pas mal ton sémites aussi en cas
laissé six tours et celui qui choisit
c'est un peu plus passif quand même à
noter quand même que le vidame entoure
ces huit lecavalier étant protégé par le
fourgon ils se disent pas la peine pas
si facile
ses huit pairs de la fourchette
domtar bon h3
voilà maintenant attention pour prendre
des sept îles en l'air parce que cavaler
prendre dame prend d'un proche de 3 chez
groix hd ya plus de perpétuels et là
j'ai une vraie pièce de plus donc il
faut calculer s'étend du bon car iachini
calcul ils voient que ça va pas pouf
voilà il sort la prise câble et c5 on
l'a vu attention problème parce qu'elle
débloque le pion à 4 est perdu quand les
blancs contre contre ce pion mais carsen
d'ibg de l'activité j'ai la colonne g
l'espace de pions ici j envisage de
devenir t'embêter et je vais monter une
attaque si tu commences à prendre les
pions et tu t'éloignes des pièces et il
ya de l'ag d'activité en échange
voilà d'abord je me leroy l'abri en h2
et je te laisse prendre le pion et
carell qui ne se privent pas calais
prend 1,4 donc là on rentre ça y est
dans une partie à des équilibres là deux
pions attention ici un de pions ici
contrôle dont un pion passé c'est les
noirs finalement comme si on passait et
carcelle lui il a de l'activité contre
le roi noir donc qui va qui va
bénéficier de
de l'activité ou du pion de plus on va
voir tour des huit voies l'attendait 8
déjà intéressant à noter que surtout
reprend on va regarder tout reprend
dimpre en échec si la dalle revenait en
fuite par exemple pour dire ben je suis
d'accord d'échangé j'aime bien ne plus
passer ça marche pas parce qu'il y
aurait cavaliers échec le roi bouge et
la dame est perdu et l'a donc on sera
obligé de jouer un coup comme roy h7
et sur quoi les blancs sans doute jouer
simplement cac valeo 5 et tout de suite
les noms des problèmes comment je
défends ça et attention parce que si le
roi noir voit le pion à vii sauter c'est
chaud c'est chaud ça devient faible et
ça fait peur parce que voilà tour des
huit donc attention donc pas de prise
mais plutôt voilà j'ai six les noirs se
disent bon il faut en cas d'échec je
puisse revenir en g7 g7today le roi
garde le contrôle sur le pion à vii et
voilà et maintenant peut-être les noirs
pourrait ensuite envisager d'échanger
bon les blancs n'ont pas peur il joue
dam des quatre dames des quatre vu que
j'ai joué j'ai six bien sûr y met
l'accent sur le fait que lecavalier
n'est pas protégé en cas de prise en des
huit échecs roi g7 ça tient mais en
classe je peux prendre du cavalier
lecavalier et si cette emprise
voilà alors les noirs choisissent de
venir en jce est protégé le cavalier qui
n'ont pas peur pour prendre la fuite
puisque dans ce cas je prends de la dame
aînée sûr pas du roi parce que cali sera
prise je prends de la dame
je reviens le roi continue à protéger
par le problème aussi c'est que la
tension en jouant roi g7
je mets mes lecavalier un an clouage
donc une idée comme g4 g5 qui on prend
lyon prend j'ai gagné une pièce
attention à ça bon c'est aux blindes
jouer et alors là car scène il fait un
coup complètement incompréhensible
certaines courbes on peut jouer plein de
coupe on peut bien jouer autour des
sceptres puisque le cas mais les prix
étant prises c'est intéressant tour 17
parce que ça cloue le pion à vii ça peut
créer des choses intéressantes on peut
envisager ensuite de jouer g4 g5 et il
ya plein de plein d'idées possible
ça aurait été intéressant on peut aussi
jouer cavalier ou 5 4 5 est super
intéressant c'est que qu'a le cng menace
de jouer cavalier 17
voilà imaginons voilà on va regarder
cavaliers aux cinq ici ça a l'air
intéressant car le 5 cl noir font pas
attention je sais pas un million
d'habitants qui jouent pas un coup comme
comme je suis pas moi cavaliers calais
c3 en trucs idiots
je pense que c'est pas bon regardez à
calais 17 sa menace voit la fourchette
le cavalier coup et si la tour prend ben
je fais dans prend échec et ensuite pour
la touche bien une pièce voilà donc à
l'eocène c'est intéressant je centralise
le cavalier je crée une petite menace il
faut que les noirs bon c'est facile à
contrer mais c'est quand même voilà
allez on sent que les pièces blanches
sont très actives on peut on peut jouer
g4 g5 après derrière bon bref
et là car c'est ni joue j'ai pas compris
ce coup là on ne comprend pas ces cinq
csn que la le pion et prix partout je
vois pas l'idée il va pas l'idée je
pensais aussi une gaffe quoi c'est une
gaffe on peut prendre du cavalier on
peut faire plein de trucs et en plus
cela car akin et il peut même échangé la
tour au passage il a protégé le cavalier
6 il le fait tout reprend celle prend
des 8es maintenant ben bouffe je prends
voilà qu'elle est pensée je gagnais un
pion et la personne est très mal qu'est
ce que c'est que ce coup alors qu'il
avait les initiatives contre le coeur la
partie était encore équilibré il
semblerait que l' attention l adoption -
depuis au moins deux pions pas s'il y
est quoi bon il un peu l'activité rome
et c'est en quoi c'est tendu
c'est hyper tendu allez une petite idée
là on va la voir tout de suite d'amd 6
c'est intéressant
l'idée de car ce n est la suivante
regardez c'est très très malin quand
même
il attaque le pion ce qui déjà permettra
de récupérer un pion
ce qui est déjà bien mais si on prend
deux pions s'éloigne de la pression sur
le roi mais l'idée elle n'est pas la
regarder
l'idéal est que le cavalier là il peut
prendre six maintenant échec
et si je prends du cavalier évidemment
il ya la dame qui perdu voilà je cloud
lecavalier
voilà donc aller proches oublie de
prendre du plomb mais si je
du pion dame échec et le cavaly là il
mal placé parce que je suis obligé de
partir avec le roi et je prends le
cavalier avec un rock etc et aux fraises
il est totalement dénudée voilà donc
c'est un petit piège que fait car celle
là mais quand même bon il a donné deux
pions pour ça et regarder car iachini
tombe pas dans le piège d'un harnais il
fait ça ici tombe un peu dans le piège
d'ailleurs en fait il fallait qu'il des
clous il fallait qu'ils des clous ce ce
cas valeo cela alors il aurait pu le
faire avec dans d'étroits par exemple
dans des troncs pendant baies 3par
imaginons de métro ou dame peut-être
même dame de 2 pourquoi pas d'âme b2c
intéressant dans b2 analysons sarsgaard
dans le b2c pas mal parce que je protège
aussi le lecavalier d'accord mais dans
ce cas là il va on aurait pu jouer et en
même temps regarder d'un bep 2 pourquoi
je le mets en b2 non seulement je bons
gènes et socar et on a vu que en cas de
damas est la cena mais aussi jeux j'ai
un oeil sur sur le pion sur le pion b6
dans ce cas là et blanc pour jouer
d'am-dam 7
il ya toujours des problèmes puisque là
je menace de prendre en effe cette voie
la loterie des dames d'un premier set
avec un quasi match
le roi est totalement aux fraises après
je pense g6 et on peut dire c'est foutu
oui j'ai même pas je mangeais pas besoin
de calculer que le temps que pyongyang
se voit bien que le roi n'a plus de
défenseur il et j'ai au moins un échec
perpétuel et j'ai senti qu'une attaque
de maths c'est cholet mais il aurait pu
sur bande des six il aurait pu jouer à
notre cou qui était intéressant aussi
c'est ici d'am dam à quatre lames à
quatre c'est intéressant parce que là
maintenant donc sur cavale et prend
aussi ses chaînes je prends du cavalier
non pas du pur en cause on a vu d'un de
cet échec je prends le cavalier ou
cavaliers pour je comprends mais les ors
les blancs peut reprendre des six b6
pardon ici sinon c'est pas le problème
l'intérêt de la maca tu sais que sur
d'allos est avec l'idée de me prendre à
vii
je peux revenir en 17 je reviens 17
je protège tous et j'ai deux points de
plus donc là il faut prendre le pion b6
il faut prendre le pion et maintenant
simplement qu'elle ait des s'est
terminée j'ai un gros point de plus et
j'ai le protéger toutes toutes les
astuces la peu car c'est là est mis en
place
y a rien en fait sur d'un v6 ou d'un bep
4-1 d'un v6 pour essayer de revenir à un
set dans des 4 c'est fini je dois partir
et mon pioli prêt à avancer
gros avantage noir donc la sueur d'amd
si cela car à qui nos lieux d'amd set
pour revenir en baisse est ici protéger
je leur offre un pion mais je protège
tout j'ai toujours un point de plus il
fait un coup tu en as tendancieux ils
tombent dans le piège en quelque sorte
d'âme des 3 alors que cette variante
semblait pas bonne car ce n est là dans
les trois tonnes dans l'idée de carsen
et oui regardez
superbe j'aime bien quand même une
petite place tactique car l'épreuve 6
quand même maintenant boom
si tu prends tu perds la dame pas
d'amendé 3 les protégés par le cavalier
je suis obligé de prendre des pions il
l'avait fait pas il ay latine il a raté
un truc j'ai l'impression alors nous 38e
coup il y avait sans doute un petit déj
note là bas j'ai pas vu le temps exact
mais bon donc f prend 2,6 alors s 36
essais aux blancs de jouer donc c'est la
petite varennes qu'on a vu dame cet
échec le roi est obligé de partir voyez
c'est assez des trucs qu'il faut
calculer ça c'est joli quand même c'est
vraiment joli comme manoeuvre un rocher
8 et maintenant on apprend m6 alors deux
pions passé lié certes mais rôle fraises
voilà donc là alors attention quand même
aux six est contrôlé par le cavalier g6
et contrôlé par la dame c'est l'idée de
karuïa keane très certainement mais
semblant de jouer non seulement de jouer
alors les noirs jouent à 4 en avant d'un
coup tu vois là bon certes moreau est un
peu aux fraises je sens que je vais
avoir une attaque mais en attendant moi
je crée une contrebasse je vais plus
espions dont tu pourras pas faire ce que
tu veux
sous peine de me voir faire dame devra
pour aller chercher ce pion mais j'aurai
le temps de revenir en défense peut-être
donc là les la partie semble se
rééquilibrer
très joli coup car scène après il faut
savoir attaquer comme ça regardez
regardez comme c'est très intelligent
e4 pourquoi au 4 mai je bouche la
défense voyez je bouge
en cas de prise je peux pas prendre la
dame cas de prise en main 4 ça la
défense reste bouché dans prend élimine
tous les pions de valleroy gbl
perpétuelle j'ai peut-être mieux parce
que mes pions il commence à devenir eux
mêmes des pions passer un pion passé
mais avec une attaque de maths c'est
plus fort que justin pions passé avec
une attaque lointaine donc la cara qui
ne revient dame g6 d'amd cette
intelligente en cas de plus en justice
j'essaie de protéger avec la dame et
voilà dans le projet 6 échecs donc
arsène a réussi son coup en échange de
pions passer la loi niemi qui sont loués
jordan quand même ici
il a dénudé le roi noir voilà le roi
noir et dénudé donc il ya il ya une
attaque
il ya une attaque et donc ça compense le
pion passé il ya au moins sans doute
peut-être un perpétuel et peut-être plus
on peu attention on a beaucoup de pions
aussi on peut maintenant avancer ses
pions l'a envoyé un riff singles et j'ai
moi aussi aime bien passé mais en plus
devant le roi donc c'est un pion qui
contrôlent des caselles contre un pion
qui peut participer à l' attaque et
voilà ils attaquent de maths c'est plus
fort que d'aller faire la main voilà
donc l'équilibré l'équipe de la terreur
1 c'est tendu là c'est vraiment une
partie tendue j'aimerais mais on est
devant la fin si j'aimerais devant les
trolls et les chics et là c'est vraiment
le moment la clé si vous voulez dans une
partie comme ça où
voilà avantage positionnelle qui ont
passé contre une attaque il faut bien
défendre et faire valoir son pion pour
gagner pour le côté noir et côté blanc
il faut attention il faut jouer très
dynamique et il jouer jouer la tacc qui
retarde cette arrivée de dames
il faut que l' attaque passent avant que
les noirs se consolide donc la dame g7
normal les noirs protège la dame huit
échecs de huit échecs callas de défense
on peut jouer soit dames et suite sans
rage cette banlieue de son bolide
ce roi h7
on peut regarder c'est parce que jouer
donc car yakine il jouerait sur rouages
7/4 scène aurait pu faire sans doute eu
pourquoi est bien celle je libère ce fou
notamment j'adorerais jouer un échec ici
évidemment le problème vient c'est qu'il
ya ce cavalier mais ce cavalier
on peut peut-être l'embêter bon alors si
les noirs poussent leurs pions ce qui
semble pas forcément une mauvaise idée
si les blancs pour jouer ici regardez
dame invite attaque le pion et on peut
pas le protéger
tout simplement donc les blancs on
récupère espion il ya plus comme si on
passait qui est loin d'aller à dame
le roi est un peu aux fraises si ce pion
plus bouge de bas lecavalier n'est pas
protégé il suffit que l'attak aidés qui
bouge
et attention il y aura un échec mortels
ici le four entre en jeu
et puis donc les blancs devront avoir un
avantage la taxe sera beaucoup plus
forte
donc c'est une possibilité mais sur
trois sets après une scène il faut pas
jouer à trois il faut sans doute à
essayer d'échanger les pièces par un
coup comme dan 17
voilà c'est une possibilité j'ajoute une
variante dame 17 là c'était possible
aussi pascal à un coup comme dame b 8
effort très certainement l'idée c'est
que j'attaque d66 b6 bouge
le cas ben ali n'est plus protégé jeu
lattaque silenor le protège peut revenir
faire des échecs contre le roi et s'il
part il ya le fameux fouet quatre échecs
le fou rentrent en jeu avec un effet
dévastateur donc attention dame g7 ici
d'un 8
il fait damer fuite mais ça c'est un
quasi une quasi proposition nul je
reviens angers si c'est bon je peux
encore jouer auront ensuite mais bon
c'est un peu joué f5 avec les blancs
peut jouer scène pour libérer le fou on
n'a pas trop peur si on passait
finalement mettre tellement de temps à
avancer que on a le temps de faire
remonter la tacc voilà donc arsène est
en équilibre dynamique la position
extrêmement tendue donc là il joue adams
et 6 bon pourquoi pas m6 attention qui
ont b6 si tu tombes des champions enfin
pas facile de l'avancé tout en gardant
le cavalier ici protéger parce que si
attention sinon le cincle faut rentrer
en jeu
toujours pareil on peut jouer cinq aussi
attention tout art avec les blancs à
tout moment ses pions peuvent avancer le
royal rang derrière et on voyait le roi
blanc lui complètement bien protégé
équilibre de la terreur d'amd 8 pour car
yakine
très bon coup d'amd vite voilà je
protège mes six qui lui-même protège le
cavalier est un petit oeil là sur eux
sur sept sur cette pénétration ici
encore maintenant s'il nous faut bouge
bien moi aussi j'aurais peut-être d
échec d'entrée qui l'obligeront à
revenir en défense et la personne donc
il dit mais bon si voilà il le fait f5
voilà on en a dit aussi soit 11,5 pour
libérer le fou soit f5 et attention
menace de prendre 6
une fois prises prise ce fou devient
actif on libère des cases d'accord donc
les noirs n'ont pas intérêt à prendre si
notez bien ça si vous prenez vous
libérer trop de cases pour ce fou qui
devient un monstrueux après prise prise
bafodé 5 entre en jeu qui bloque en plus
la pénétration de l'adhan en attaque sur
le roi donc c'est à la fois un fou en
attaque qui en plus de bouches une
colonne et le renoir voir des problèmes
il ya un flou il ya un pion un pion
attention je le pousse à un f6 je
contrôlais cases noires le foot qu'on
sur les cases blanches
la dame est en attaque attention
attention attention les noirs sont sous
pression la fcm c'est très fort
emeghara qui ne tombe pas dans le piège
il le sait il ouvre pas il joue à trois
voire la superbe ville dilatation
regarde je protège b6 cavale et là tu
empêches devenir un clac prends ta
question comment tu fais pour l'arrêter
lui à 2 à 1
il veut pas l'arrêter car cindy b tu va
le pousser mais moi je vais te re et je
vais te faire matam ans donc il prend
1,6 voilà bah oui alors attention là
maintenant ça devient extrêmement tendue
ce pion réussite à 2 càs de dames
le roi est pas loin d échec possible
bon mais les noirs sont aussi pas loin
de faire d'avancé tant dublin c'est
chaud imaginons que les noirs ici jouent
à a2a les caisses qui se passe là faut
calculer alors garder la position assez
tactique l'inla c'est un truc de
champion du monde
allez je vous le fais bon simplement de
7,7 suffi puisque je suis à une classe
de faire dame
la dame est obligé de prendre donc le
set est maintenant simplement je fais
damas huit échecs roi en g7 ou sans
doute même en âge c'est tout je souhaite
notre bon aussi soucasse noir simplement
maintenant je prends le pion
et maintenant ce pion avant qu'ils
viennent de faire dame on va créer des
menaces est ce que les noirs peuvent
prendre le pion eu quatre ici
certainement pas puisque simplement ont
fait regarder dames 2 le cavalier cloud
et si je sors ces prises donc au
prochain coup je deviens une pièce et
les blancs ont bien sûr ici partie
gagnante très certainement pas c'est sûr
c'est pas très certainement c'est sûr
voilà donc se référant aux six attention
voilà les noirs s'ils poussent à 2
simplement c'est donc les cakin joue un
coup mal un intéressant roger cette voie
là 3g sept coups intéressants je ne
pousse pas je m'enlève d'un échec en a
huit
et oui il ya plus d chacun 8
d'intentions menace à 2 toujours sur
cette dame prend un bain tu fais quoi
pour arrêter dit quoi cette immunité
coincé donc attention donc la carcel ne
craque pas il joue le bon coup attention
oui ou non
ouf e set quand même d'en prendre cette
force et sinon ces dames et maintenant
il fait le très joli très simple d'en
prendre b6 voilà tu apprends il élimine
un pion en ré l'opt été préféré éliminer
celui là quand même parce que là est bon
il élimine celui là ce qui est bien mais
dans le cas de la 2 6 à 2 et bien d'un
bep 2 échecs et oui voilà c'est une
défense elle direct il faut pas que le
pire arrive en a deux il serait trop
proche de faire dame ou alors faut
vraiment qu'ils aient une attaque
toujours équilibre ici les noirs
totalement poussé le roi est toujours
voilà c'est ça le point clé lors on est
toujours faible
c'est une très très belle finale un
équilibre des erreurs moi on a envoyé
que même avec dame
voilà adam une pièce bien il ya encore
il ya encore des menaces de matty encore
des menaces suffisante pour contrer
comme ça un avantage matériel donc
cavaliers detroit
c'est très très belle partie à la fois
en attaque et en défense cariat qui nous
replace ces pièces caïds et 3 c'est
vraiment un coup intéressant
il protège à trois avec la dame il veut
sans doute replacer son cavalier en cinq
blocs le pion aux quatre le fou est mort
le fou et reste en défense et passifs et
pourquoi pas mais continuer à se
consolider et essayer de trouver un
moyen d'arriver à pousser ce pion encore
d'une case
attention car scène il faut vraiment
être très très très actif ici et là ils
jouent dame à 5 alors d'un masque mais
je n'empêche que plus on avance et et
ben je veux contrôler aussi c'est orange
est là donc je peux essayer peut-être
plus tard de devenir coulisser sur s'est
rangé pour venir embêter les noirs en
tout cas j'ai un oeil sur à 5
donc les normes ne peuvent pas jouer
d'un médecin qui paverait le pion il
peut jouer qu'à aller au cem ce genre de
truc mais il joue encore mieux car elle
initie attention c'est en u15 c'est
peut-être pas le meilleur là il aurait
peut-être pu trouver un coût plus précis
car scène parce que cardiaque input mc5
super fort comme ces cinq gardes trois
avions en cas d' échange celles-ci foutu
pour les pour les blancs on peut pas
empêcher le plein de faire d'un faut
garder d'un jeu que j'ai pas d'échec là
pour attendre pas d'échec à sept ses
prix c'est cette ses prix il reste bien
entendu d'un à six voilà je suis
toujours un oeil sur a2 bon ça a l'air à
peu près bon ça fait un peu peur mais on
voit que les blancs là pour attaquer le
roi noir c'est pas si simple
il a damn car les contrôles beaucoup de
cases et il ya des endroits où le roi
peut se cacher
peut-être que les noirs peuvent essayer
de se mettre en route pour avancer ses
pions donc en tout cas il joue cavalier
scène voilà c'est elle que l'idée de
recentrage du cavalier en c5 qui vient
de s'ouvrir des ieg bloc le pion il est
proche du roi nous qui peut venir
défendre roi donc la dame pour y venir
peut-être en b 4 où ces trois des quatre
je sais pas pour vous mais en b2 et
protégé l'arrivée de ce pion et
attention un cavalier proche d'un roi ça
défend très très très bien si la dame
est tombée deux déjà les cases noires
trollé le cac valeo f7 empêchera la dame
de fer des échecs là car scène il doit
trouver les bons coups 1
sinon c'est foutu peut-être qu'il faut
déjà tout de suite faire un échec ici en
baisse est par exemple ici d'un bébé cet
échec était possible il assure cavaliers
en scène par exemple défensive voilà ça
c'est une alors ça faut le savoir un
contre une dame c'est super solide voilà
très difficile d'aller faire des échecs
un endroit que comme ça et à peut-être
revenir en a 8 pour empêcher le pion
d'avancé c'est pas simple donc la halle
6 cavaliers 500 personnes fassent
attention il joue dames 6 aïe
alors là le problème c'est que ça a
l'air bon puisque à la fois ce baisse à
mai hanoi sur le câble et on ne peut pas
bouger la dame on veut et ça protège à
deux et ça reste proche du roi adverse
donc cela va être un très bon coup ça a
l'air et la regarder un très très beau
coup de khanaqine ici pas facile à boire
même complètement invisible en fait on
semaine pour qu'on n'a pas envie de
jouer du tout mais pourtant c'est un
super coup voilà h5 incroyable sec
quel petit des dons coup pareil
réfléchissez un peu je vous laisse
réfléchir à la hcmc magnifique
surtout pas
imaginez là que les blancs jouent un
coup comme j'ai pas moi les dames
d'amadou tiens amadou sall arbon d'un b3
faut trouver un coup le premier élément
aussi c'est ça le secret c'est une zone
où un petit peu h5 à toi à toi de jouer
trouver un coup violent coup obligé de
quitter la dame la classe de 6,6 ou
alors on joue hk très bien sur le mois
mais jusqu'à 100 comme dans la partie
donc on va on va plutôt se trouvait
notre coup imaginons coup comme dalida
massis la dame assise salaires bon
tomber 3 c'est là mon fils d'amadou
tient évidemment d anjou damas deux
voies la dame à 2 parce qu'à l'aller
noir
regardez je voulais simplement dame c3
et là on comprend l'idée du courage
tienne c'est que on peut menacer h4 qui
est attaque g3 et si on prend bien et
casement qui peuvent être faible
attention ici ici on peut venir en b2 et
scylla si la dame bouge il ya un clouage
ici cavaliers trois échecs avec un quasi
match que font les blancs ici ça le
problème
alors imaginons qu'ils reviennent en a
eu six c'est bien ça a l'air bon ça
parce que ici janouille sur le cavalier
et je contrôle toujours la casa deux
d'accord mais pas de problème regarder
d'un bep 2 voilà je garde année sur le
cavalier et non non je viens de b2 voilà
ça y est attention voyage
il faut faire attention alors là faut
faire les échecs échec donc là s'il aura
beau je vous laisse regarder un échec
perpétuelle donc il faut revenir aux
recettes
heureusement puisque ce cas à limonest
menacé de venir en f3 avec un quasi
match c'est ça le problème ici regardez
c'est que imaginer la bombe et je
parlais blanc jouant koubbi dans
dam des cinq pour que vous compreniez la
menace quand même c'est matt regard des
qualifs 3 regardez clouage échec revient
à chaque dame c'est un seimat faut
mettre le feu au sénat donc là sur un
coup comme si je reviens sur d'un à deux
dames c3 qu'ici sur damas damas six
dames b2i si voix la dame cet échec
voilà cabello 7-6 aux blues jouer et
comment on fait pour empêcher ça alors
on peut encore tenter eux 5
ça libère le fou ça menace devenir un f6
bon et après à deux je voulais dit ça
c'est extrêmement solide on peut pas
renier le fou là en attaque puisqu'il
est loué et sur échec trois fuites ya
plus d'échec je vous le fais quand même
échec aura une fuite
toutes les cases ici up sont prises donc
il reste le coût de 6 à l'air
intéressant ici aussi sli débat oui
évidemment on sait prendre fcp ça c'est
assez simple simplement on vient et fils
à toi regardez la dame contrôler la case
de promotion s'il ya échange en f 7
on échange tout est le fruit ne peut
plus arrêter le pion et donc c'est foutu
quoi
c'est foutu
il reste rien période il ya dame au
prochain coup y'a pas de défense oui
donc h5 coude attentes en k 2 h théâtre
attention il y aurait deux gk turgis h
quatre ans contrôlent aussi les 15
contre le roi mais simplement on
pourrait prendre comprendrez aussi c'est
peut-être un coup aussi à la jcat
l'attrition peu et on peut tenter g4
alger 4 à ce cas là voilà les noirs
prennent prises ici les blancs prennent
dans ce cas là les noirs pour jouer
damascène qui menace
à deux on garde un contrôle sur le
cavalier et si damas de ici pour les
pour les blancs afin de justement
bloqués ici mais c'est très très passif
on revient en c3 et c'est fini c'est
fini parce qu'on peut venir en b2 on
menace cavale et pranger quatre échecs
les regarder les blancs n'ont rien
contre le roi
finalement ce roi un peu en l'air voyez
il est mieux protégé par son cavalier
finalement que l'autre par le fou dans
cette position et tout ça avec le coup
imprécis de car c'est avant tout à
l'heure un secousses ku'damm aussi cela
qui qui en fait n'est pas le meilleur
voilà ici il y avait encore la
possibilité là de jouer des coups comme
d'hab et cet échec et continue à faire
des menaces tant que le pion on n'était
pas à pousser
il n'a pas réussi à trouver le bon coup
là carsen dames 6 sans doute une faute à
5 très bon coup un sans doute le coup
gagnant un coup d'attentes en fait en
quelque sorte un coup d'attendre quand
même temps voyez on l'a vu en pêche des
g4 affaibli un petit peu le roi et les
blancs n'ont pas de coût sans subsides
en fait c'est ça qui est terrible et
joue car c'est quand même h4h 4 quand
même bon mais on se dit mais le problème
nhk vous voyez maintenant qu'on a le
pion à 5 ces voix là pouf
un échec du cavalier protégé par le pion
et c'est le roi blanc qui mate
c'est terrible c'était quasi matt donc
il faut faire attention surtout que
après h4 la callas qui ne joue un
magnifique coup on regarde et écoute
déviation superbe magnifique à la
kératine super bien profiter l'a27 de
cette erreur de carsen là cela me cissé
puis cette tentative d'attaqué gêné
général le coup c'est ça qui était un
peu imprécis aussi de quartier ni là
mais sans doute mieux il n'a pas réussi
à la déjouer les déjouer les pièces
qu'elle
piège car yakine un petit peu de joueurs
semblent fatigués quand même parce qu'on
l'a vu tout à l'heure aussi car c'est ne
pouvait faire la petite combinaison de
carsen n'était pas n'était pas bonne et
carla qu'il n'a pas vu comment la
contrer avec damas quatre on a vu tout à
l'heure je vous invite à revoir le
moment bref h4 c'est un quart à kin de
jouet magnifique où après h 5 h 5 très
très bon coup on a vu beaucoup
d'attentes et en même temps qui met la
pression
les blancs n'ont toujours pas de coups
h4 on vient de voir des possibilités et
il vous regarde et a2a yahia il donne le
pion là ils menacent de faire dame donc
là les blancs n'ont pas le choix faut
prendre le pion et l'idée de ce coup
c'est de dévier la dame de l'attak du
roi sur la dame n'en pour faire un échec
est obligé d'aller nulle part parce que
ici aurait fait c'est d'ailleurs ici
c'est super ce coin de la case de cet
été prises dont il n'y a pas d'échec
voilà ici a pas d'échec
regardez-la ici sur ce coup là et bien
qu'arsène il sera 2 carsen abandonne
faut voir ce qui se serait passé si
l'abandon c'est incroyable coup de
tonnerre s'il avait joué dans prend à
deux ici cavale et j 4 échecs
le roi est obligé d'aller en h3 parce
que sur h un essai où surgit un il peut
pas puisqu'il ya la dame
attention d'un missile contrôle bien sûr
h 1 il est quasiment dans un couloir le
fou et le cavalier protège il suffit de
faire échec
on est obligé de donner le fou d'en
prendre ces matches qui restent
roger 3 seul coup on voit bien déjà
qu'il est foutu ça ça bloque
la dame a pas d'échec contre le roi
alors pas sur les classements ici mais
il suffit pour les noirs de jouer le
magnifique dame j'ai eu menace maths et
les blancs n'ont pas d'échec en ascète
il pourrait tenter un échec en b2 sinon
un échec en b2 ici échec le roi dans ce
cas là leur viande g6 et c'est fini et
plus d'échecs regardez il suffit de
calculer ça en regard des rois g6 finit
plus d'échec je peux pas venir en bus si
c'est toujours la dalle et c
je vais ou nulle part donc je mets la
smat donc c'est un peu comme dans la
partie il faut jouer fouet f3 seul coup
post 3 dans ce cas là on n'y a pas de
damages deux échecs match puisque ya la
dame qui contrôlent h 2 mai mais né il
ya le match de la veille le cavalier
senna tu as fait ici le roi est
complètement pris il faut donner la dame
en fait c'est pareil obligé de donner la
dame pour contrer ce quasi matois donc
où viennent d'où vient l'erreur ici de
carsen heures sans nous donner le pion
c5 on l'a vu tout à l'heure c'était déjà
pas très bon on peut revenir dessus
alors c'était c'était avant lui deux
erreurs on a 7 partie 2 carsen sanou csn
n'est pas nécessaire car il n'a pas
trouvé en rappelez vous après après les
coups suivants ici voilà il avait il a
joué dam des trois il est quand même
tombé dans le petit village de carsen
qu'il a permis de revenir dans la partie
mais ici même le ku'damm à quatre on l'a
vu était très fort il l'a raté il a raté
à ce moment là très certainement secoue
damas quatre lits des dames à 86
l'avenir protéger le roi en 17
on rend le pion db6 dans quatre prisons
v6 simplement joue qu'avec 1,17 et on a
un gros pions d'avancé avec le roi
tranquille déjà c'est un premier une
première erreur de karaj akin enfin
première erreur de kars l écart là qu'il
n'a pas trouvé forcément les meilleurs
coups et la deuxième erreur il
semblerait que donc ce soit et bien ce
coup là dame 6,7 déjà un peu difficile
pour qu'arsène avoir donné et plus ont
passé là mais donc c'est bien avant
voilà ici c'est pas si voix la capitale
tout ça c'était bon de carsen voilà ils
avaient de l'attak
il a très bien joué il a récupéré ce
pion bon ok là il peut encore s'en
sortir ce coquin et menaçant un scorpion
et menaçant mais il peut jouer contre le
roi il peut essayer de pousser ses pions
pour libérer un peu le fou il peut voilà
il peut encore faire des choses lama si
ça va encore voilà dans le si cela voilà
dame six erreurs là il peut encore s'en
sortir en peut-être c'est déjà difficile
je pense quand même
c'est quand même déjà un peu difficile
mais il peut faire des échecs
ici dans cet échec essayer de repousser
ce cavalier d'activer peut-être de
certifier le pion mais aussi pour les
pour activer son fou ce fou qui
d'ailleurs en venant au centre ici en
dessin pourrait non seulement attaqué le
quatrième set si les blancs les noirs se
défendre mais aussi pour y contrôler à
casa 2 voilà c'est un coup comme dame
bessette ici aurait peut-être été
meilleure avec au bon il faut revenir
pour empêcher le perpétuel pour
l'épauler bhl pour les noirs menace
calenge où damas huit voix là et on
garde le contrôle sur la diagonale ici
qui va nous permettre plus tard
l'envisager de jouer le fou en dessins
sont éliminés ce cavalier même avec le
pion de plus peut-être qu'on peut faire
on peut arriver à faire un perpétuel
voilà en tout cas coup de tonnerre parti
quand même magnifique moi jouer car
celle qui a joué à fond on peut pas dire
le contraire mais voilà après abdallah
il abandonne à cause de la voir qu'on a
vu et cariat qu'il prend prend donc
l'avantagé dans ce championnat du monde
c'est chaud pour qu'arsène attention et
c'était la partie 8 9 10 11 12 il reste
quatre parties à carsen pour revenir
dans le match
je pensais la première fois depuis qu'il
est champion du monde qu'il ait mis
comme ça devant un peu au pied du mur il
est au pied du mur car scène face à une
carrière qui a tenu tenu tenu et qu'il a
profité voilà d'une fin de match
peut-être une légère déconcentration de
car ce n est qu à rien qui ne réussit à
marquer le point bon sens car c'est
quand même la possibilité de revenir il
n'a montré des parties précédentes
mais il est en difficulté mais c'est
peut-être là qu'on va voir si c'est un
grand champion du monde est ce qu'il est
capable voilà de de revenir un peu à la
casse parrot enfin rappelez vous les
matchs contre karpov
c'est un moment historique à ce
moment-là moment de temps du nom qu'il
va qui va de rester dans l'histoire là
car c'est les dominer donc soit karékine
ii vient nouveau champion du monde le
17e soi car celle des montres la super
classe et il revient il revient dans le
match pour arriver à l'emporter a et b
on verra on sait pas encore
moment historique en ce moment merci
d'avoir suivi cette partie soit déloyale
tv c'était la partie 8 de ce championnat
du monde 2016 carsen cariat kiné rendez
vous donc pour la prochaine partie
au revoir